you need something to be excited about
when you wake up in the morning and
something that you're doing that has has
a purpose balance is important I think
that you have to remember to find some
time for yourself I have a strong will
and I'm very determined I always look at
the glass half-full I try to have a
positive attitude
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from Kris Jenner and my
take on her top ten rules for success
you need something to be excited about
when you wake up in the morning and
something that you're doing that has has
a purpose and if you do something that
you love and you have this amazing
energy behind it it's like it makes life
so much better and you can develop
something and create a career for
yourself out of something that you love
to do a lot of how you live your life
and how you succeed in life is who you
associate yourself with and who your
friends are and my parents taught me
that my whole life and I heard my
friend's parents say it and then Robert
Kardashian drilled it into my older four
kids you know they're most of their
lives and it just was ringing true it's
like you associate and and and hang out
with people that are like-minded or that
you want to be like and then you go out
and do it balance is important I think
that you have to remember to find some
time for yourself
because if you're not the best that you
can be then you're not good to anyone
else so I think balance is about finding
and catching yourself making scheduling
like I'll schedule a massage it sounds
silly but I you know carry all my stress
in my neck so I just if I can get that
relief you know once a week or once
every two weeks I feel really blessed so
I think you have to find the thing
whether it's exercise I exercise every
morning changes my whole day if I don't
exercise I'm thrown off so I think that
you have to listen to your body and do
what makes you feel your best
so that you can do your best otherwise
you're no good to anybody else I have a
young daughter Kendall who's 16 years
old her dream in life is to be a model
that's all she's ever wanted to be and
now she's going to be on the cover of a
major magazine in September she the
girls were just on the cover of Teen
Vogue Kendall and Kylie are getting one
of the most incredible business
education that I think is possible in
you know in the history of all little at
that
they're constantly they go to their
business meetings there's one business
meeting they went to with Ryan Seacrest
and his whole team Adam share and
everybody and they were at this long
conference table and after the meeting
Ryan was like wow that blew me away you
know they were amazing because they show
up they are ready for the meeting
they've done their homework and they've
got all these things that they're
working on right now that's gonna blow
you away when you hear about it in six
months I had raised four kids in this
opulent lifestyle with this amazing you
know anything they they wanted there was
never a fear of you know a money thing
they had their very privileged lives and
so then when I got married the second
time and it wasn't the same pocketbook
you know it was it was much different
and you I was faced with I've got to
learn how to get it together and so the
fear was that I would disappoint anybody
because I am a people pleaser but I'm
also very I have a strong will and I'm
very determined so once I set my mind to
something and I knew that this had to
happen and then I found a way to make a
change and that's what was so rewarding
and satisfying because I would work so
hard all day long things started to
happen because I figured out a way to
have an income for my family and then
the hard work didn't scare me because
every time I would go to bed at night
and put my head on the pillow I was like
this is so I had such a great day this
felt so good and I worked so hard
finally had a pop-up store in New York
which I heard was it last week and it
was the turnout was crazy really crazy
with thousands of people that showed up
and it was quite the quite the scene
there in New York City but it turned out
really well and look at that people were
there days before it there was one woman
who camped out there with her kids for
like three days before it opened and I
felt so bad but Kylie so proud of those
shops and she has mostly an e-commerce
business mhm so to do this is just
something she likes to do she's gonna
she thinks I think she thinks that she's
going to go
on like a national tour now so she'll do
the different cities and she's having a
really good time but but she's selling
things with your face on it did you know
that I mean like there's a lighter right
here by the way it's like $12 for that
lighter did you know that I did not know
she will doing any merch with my face
well until it came out and she kind of
did it and surprised me and I was like
oh boy but I I mean doesn't she have to
ask your permission like well she I
could sue her exactly exactly yeah that
doesn't Bajor lost yeah that's why I'm
having you here is educate you that you
should thank you
yeah Ellen but I think it's just crazy
that she's pretty you gotta laugh at
yourself I mean when I saw this I was I
thought it was so funny that one's a
little x-ray that's blurred out yeah cuz
she out said she does her and I have a
really good relationship and all my kids
have such great senses of humor and
we're so silly all the time and you have
to you know have a good sense of humor
and not take yourself so serious how do
you manage being a mother wife and such
a huge businesswoman how does it all
happen it's I feel sometimes like I have
a different job every day you know which
I enjoy because there's a lot of
diversity and there it's always
something different and I think that
when you're passionate about something
it comes easy but the key is being very
organized you know making a lot of lists
and you know I'm a control freak so
sometimes it's hard to give things up
when I do something I don't really think
of like I always look at the glass
half-full
I try to have a positive attitude I try
to see through the mud and say this
could be a really great thing because
I'm gonna do it different or I'm gonna
make this you know work or I'm always
very I'm very stubborn for one and I
don't like to let things go so if I
start doing something and it's not going
well
I'll I think I'm so persistent that I
will do it until I feel like it's good
or right so you have this next
generation yes
and the two younger ones that would
Kiley spotlight as well yes
is that going to keep your family
relevant for another 15 years well
here's the thing about that question I
don't it's not about keeping the family
relevant it's about and this is what
I've always taught my children find your
dream and get what's your passion but
you girls are getting a workout aren't
you I'm having a really good time can we
try it can you show us okay okay you in
the audience
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the what
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jade cherry
asked me to if there's someone you'd
like to vote on for the next top ten
check out the link in the description
and go and have your say finally I want
to give a quick try to - Jane Cassell
Jane thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and for
posting it on your social media accounts
on your length in I really appreciate
the support and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the read so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
what motivates you to keep going because
you really don't have to do anything if
you don't want to you know you know what
I think that for me it keeps me alive
like inside spiritually and and just
with my passion about what I want to be
able to teach someone else and I think
that it's important when they asked me
to do this I thought wow what a great
opportunity I thought it was such a
perfect idea for a private school to be
able to bring you know this - I thought
I had something to share you know I've
had I've had to kind of figure it out
myself from the ground up taking kind of
nothing and making a business out of it
and figuring it out and if I have
anything to offer somebody else it would
be so exciting for me to be able to do
that instead of just you know my five
kids I can only [ __ ] at them for so
many hours a day before they just tuned
me out you know but to be able to have
it as an organized education and come in
from time to time and be able to give a
seminar or a lecture and be a part of
such an amazing process especially in
international school because I love
traveling so much and I love seeing I
love learning something new every day if
as long as you can keep on learning and
then to be able to share something with
someone else I think that's amazing